أجنبي أجنبي ،
نعم ، أعتقد أنه سؤال رائع مرة أخرى ،
ومرة ​​أخرى ، الإجابة
مضمنة في السؤال ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، نعم ، هناك حاجة ماسة لطريقتين ،
الطريقة الوحيدة هي الأشخاص الذين
يأتون إلى هنا ويقفون أمام
بابا باتيستا ويقولون ما هو  هذا
ما هو هذا لماذا هذا هنا حتى يبدأوا
في التساؤل عن الأسئلة الجيدة كيف
جاءت هنا لماذا يرون في
بلدنا آه لماذا لا يزال قائماً
كيف يمكنني الاتصال به حتى أن التاريخ
مثل الحقيقة ليس بعدًا واحدًا إنه ليس كذلك
الأسود الأبيض دائمًا متعدد الألوان ، لذا فهم
يأتون إلى هنا إلى إفريقيا
أم
زوار أجانب ودوليين وهذا
ناجح لأنهم يمنحون
سوريا والعراق وجهة النظر المصرية
لشيئين ولديهم
ملاك آخر يبحث عن شيئين وهذا هو  من
المفيد جدًا للزوار أن يفهموا
أكثر حتى يكون هناك شخص ما من سوريا
أمامك ، لماذا تتطلع إلى
سلام سوري هو أمر مفيد للغاية لأنه
بعد ذلك يمكنك أن تسأل ما هو
معنى ذلك وكيف تتصل
به وأنت  لقد رأينا أن هناك الكثير من
التعاطف والتعاطف لمعرفة المزيد
عن الثقافة العربية أيضًا من جميع
الزوار القادمين ، إنها
ناجحة جدًا نسميها وجهة النظر الأخرى ،
لذا يعطي الناس وجهة نظر أخرى
ثم
علماء الآثار العاديين أو المؤرخ الألماني الحضري
على الرغم من أن لديهم وجهة نظر أكثر مباشرة من
شخص ما ، فهذا رائع ، نعم ،
نعم